[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we've been covering a lot of
these failed lethal injection executions
as part of death penalty the carrying
out of death penalty sentences and
increasingly there are problems I mean
listen there have been problems with
lethal injection for a long time but
increasingly there are problems because
of lack of availability of some of the
chemicals that are used there have also
been a lot of incidents where people
failed to die for 40 or 50 or 60 minutes
after these injections have been given
and that starts to create questions
about cruel and unusual punishment aside
from the fact that I would argue killing
someone counts even if it goes perfectly
as planned but the news is that the
state of Oklahoma is now going to start
using nitrogen gas to execute death row
inmates going forward nobody has tried
this so far in response to the
difficulty of obtaining these lethal
injection drugs now Oklahoma hasn't even
carried out an execution in more than
three years because of these very
high-profile mistakes that have been
made including one that a grand jury has
called an inexcusable failure that took
who knows how long before it was
ultimately called off so the the problem
here is that there's really no protocol
for using nitrogen gas that's been
created yet right so with each one of
these drugs
in theory there's a protocol that
dictates exactly how much per inmate
weight and in what order and how is it
all meant to be administered and often
it still fails right I mean we have
numerous incidents where people either
fail to die or die after what seems to
be a pretty agonizing 20 30 40 or even
50 minutes with nitrogen gas there's not
even an execution protocol that's been
put in place yet but I guess it's an
attempt to try to deal with the problems
that have been ongoing and growing with
lethal injections what about just saying
hey you know what we're not gonna do it
any right right what about that as the
power
forward feel as if we're searching for
the most humane style of execution and
we've been doing that for a long time
back in the day they would you know hang
draw and quarter people and they would
burn people at the stake and
progressively we got a little bit more
humane you could say with it even like
with the guillotine that's like a quick
chop of the head assuming it was
correctly assumed anyways you know we've
move on to electrocution we move on to
lethal injection people are trying to
find a way to make it done humanely and
get it over with quickly yeah and this
is just the next step I think I but it
isn't really the next step to get rid of
the death penalty like that's really as
a society we should just recognize that
the concept is actually what's inhumane
and we should just do away with it
altogether and yeah I still am sort of
in the camp that we're going in that
direction because we've had never more
than today have we had more States say
we're no longer doing the death penalty
so I still see us as going in that
direction but it's probably gonna be a
longer path than for example the path to
national gay marriage which really
accelerated very very quickly and now
you can't have state bans on same-sex
marriage anymore I think it's gonna be a
much longer process than that and it
already has been given how long we've
seen well some states start to do the
outlawing of the death penalty but I'm
still hopeful yeah but if the nitrogen
gas works for Oklahoma and the inmates
don't seem to experience any pain and
actually go out in a somewhat euphoric
way are you Forex stupor I think that
could last for another 10 or 20 years
don't you uh well I mean there are many
other reasons beyond just that some of
these chemicals haven't been working
super well to get rid of the death
penalty like anti-death activism isn't
going to stop if nitrogen gas seems to
work pretty well you know so I'm still
hopeful and obviously we want to avoid
any execution if there are going to be
some I get it's like I almost feel like
I'm buying into the concept of the death
penalty and I say a more humane
execution is better than a less humane
execution there is if there is one there
even isn't one so I don't even really
like saying that but certainly dying in
a euphoric stupor on nitrogen gas seems
better than lasting an hour while they
poke and prod and put different
chemicals into you and you hear to be
sort of uh fixating yourself
although there is one caveat to this
which is that you have to kind of
participate in your own execution in
order you've got a real smoothly because
you have to breathe yeah if people are
fighting for their lives they may choose
to hold their breath for a couple of
minutes and that has to be interpreted
as cruel and unusual punishment well I
mean I I don't want to get too morbid
but I guess what would happen is you
hold your breath long enough to at most
pass out and then your breathing resumes
involuntarily and they'd just be a mask
up to your face we can't have that
and that's probably it but yeah it
doesn't doesn't seem good but I don't
know that it'd be much of a strong
effort to resist I think ultimately it's
gonna happen there's a French Baker who
is not adhering to the rules of
work/life balance in France and he is
being slapped with a three thousand euro
fine for working too hard this is
exactly what people like Bill O'Reilly
talk about when they say they're so lazy
over there in Europe he was baking and
the biggest problem was that he had his
shop open too much seven days a week and
the laws require one weekly day of rest
for businesses and he now is being
defended by the mayor of the town where
they live saying listen it's a touristy
place it's good that the business is
busy he should be allowed to stay open
seven days a week and he wants if he
wants it's actually sort of necessary if
you're doing tourist business to be open
all the time because tourists come
year-round every day of the week and
there are a lot of people who are
functioning in support of him but he is
in violation of those labor laws and
France I kind of love this story I mean
I actually do think that the business
should be allowed to be open seven days
if they want to I think that's a little
heavy-handed
I think what's good is limiting any one
person's work right and the problem
though is when you have a small business
if you don't have employees the only way
to be open seven days a week might be
for him to be there seven days a week so
I sort of understand the point of the
law but based on our American
sensibilities it does seem sort of
heavy-handed yeah I feel like it's okay
to have working limits for employees
yeah but if this is a small business and
he's the only one work
there maybe it's his call to determine
how much he wants to work and I think
it's reasonable to assume that there's
no coercion there it's not like his boss
is making him work extra hours sure he's
the boss yeah and about that you know
you could have a lot that distinguishes
and says that as an employee who is in a
sort of what the equivalent of a w-2
situation you can't force them nor
threaten their jobs because they don't
want to work seven days a week I think
that that's perfectly reasonable as an
entrepreneur and business owner I don't
know it feels a little bit much to say
he can't be open seven days a week I
don't know it's I'm having trouble with
what's the justification for it are the
French saying that this is for his own
well-being basic or is it more so that
it's in order to create fair competition
so that other bakeries aren't
incentivized to also work 17 I've not
heard that I know it hurts yeah no I've
not heard that argument I've heard that
it is just it appears to be just part of
this work-life balance and France I
believe also now I might be getting
mixed up in which countries have done
this but I believe it's France that has
also passed a law saying employees who
work like regular hours can't be
penalized for not responding to email
like after 7:00 p.m. or something like
that like if they want to they if they
want to they can but they can't be
penalized for that
and they also I believe have reduced the
normal working week is it to 35 or 32
hour I don't remember now but anyway
France is doing some interesting stuff I
find it all very very interesting I
would be so angry if I worked extra hard
in your own business extra hours yeah
yeah and then instead of making more
money I lose money I'd be irate well
that's I think the argument right which
is you're you're working longer to make
more money but in the end you'll end up
with less money because you'll be fine
so you might as well just take that one
day a week off big picture I agree it's
terrible to be going in and opening but
opening a bakery seven days a week I
mean they start very very early and it's
not good it's it's it is actually
terrible I just am unsure about the
government telling entrepreneurs when
they are allowed to work based on what
they want to do remember a clock boy
clock boy is that Muslim kid who was
arrested after taking
the homemade clock to his school and
there has now been a dismissal with
prejudice by Judge Sam Lindsay of Dallas
and the fact that the case has been
dismissed with prejudice means that
there can be no more lawsuits filed
against the family I'm sorry by the
family in regard to this case and the
part of this was that they were sort of
going on a tour of firing lawsuits over
what took place and now that the
dismissal with prejudice has taken place
they're not going to be able to do that
anymore apparently the judge felt that
they were sort of clogging up the legal
system here and they also ordered that I
think that that they might be liable for
legal fees going forward as well how
long ago did the clock boy thing even
start I don't really like two or three
years ago I imagined you covered it at
the time of course absolutely it was
your take on it my take was that you
know if a if a white kid had brought a
homemade clock to school would there
have also been the reaction that it
might be a bomb and I my I couldn't say
one way or the other but it felt weird
it definitely felt weird hard to say but
also I think the thing kind of looks
like a bomb it was in a suitcase there's
a whole bunch of wiring I don't deny
that I know this little timer thing yeah
I think there should be some precaution
there right I don't disagree that it's
not exactly your grandmother's
grandfather clock grant well I guess it
would be a grandmother clock in that
case it's not the type of antique clock
or the type of clock that everybody
universally identifies as a clock I get
that but I still at the time and the
exact original details now sort of elude
me I remember thinking at the time that
there was definitely going to be a
different reaction if it was a an
upper-class white yeah that's probably
dropped this thing in you know wouldn't
it right exactly the same but he got to
meet with the president he spoke with
Obama for a few minutes yeah but I think
the problem too is that his address was
leaked online uh someone like tweeted it
out you can't basically Docs and that
led to the moving of the family they
have to Qatar and it's I mean are we
ready to say that this is the end of the
clock boy saga yeah I mean if they can't
file any more lawsuits I think it is
yeah I think this might be the the
the last we hear from them until the kid
becomes like an amazing engineer or he
comes up with some amazing invention or
something incredible yeah yeah okay
what else do we have going on this week
we've got the Friday show we have some
new cryptocurrency content that's going
to be coming to YouTube very very soon
next week we are going to have an
interview with a real Exorcist yes now
by Davis by real all I mean is the
Exorcist isn't doing it as a goof
they believe that they are really an
exorcist but I don't really believe
there is such a thing as exorcism so by
definition I don't believe in the
concept of a real Exorcist I just mean
someone who believes themselves to be an
exorcist as opposed to like if if I were
to pretend to do an exorcism I wouldn't
be a real Exorcist in that I don't
believe that I'm actually doing anything
yeah you should ask Rachel to give you
an exorcism right on the spot via Skype
if she's able to if she's able to yeah I
don't know how that works I know that
Reiki can be done remotely now which is
super convenient for the practitioners
because they can just take your credit
card right over right over the phone and
move on to the next client or sucker as
I would call it I don't know if it works
the same way with Exorcist but we will
find out that'll be very interesting
next week and I think it's a good couple
weeks coming up on the show the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]